hello welcome back to gang Sports
coverage of e3 2016 I just knocked back
a hot double espresso feeling good one
to talk about more video games
very happy to be joined by Brent dis
brow with Dawn of War 3 Alexa ray Korea
as well hey man thank you so much for
joining us this morning
brent has your III been so far it's been
fantastic we've had you know we've had
the chance to show off the gameplay that
we sort of got people excited about the
return of dawn of War 3 with that story
trailer right several weeks ago and now
we're actually showing off gameplay and
that's that's really exciting people are
very happy so far yeah it's been wild
like six seven years at this age seven
years since there's since Donna work too
but we had the expansion packs right
softens the blow a bit yeah yeah time
time flies I guess when when you are
still releasing video games so I guess
you kind of shifted up the the rules a
bit on the second game what are you
doing with Dawn of War three every is a
horizontal or one or do you know what we
when we started it we start took a look
at our past right and we had a lot of
success with Dawn of War one with the
sort of large scale of battle and base
building and if Dawn or two we sort of
went in a different direction and had a
lot of success with the heroes mhm and
what we found was they kind of appealed
to slightly different audiences so we're
talking to on War three and what we
could do we thought you know what
spectacular battle spectacular
large-scale battles they're a lot of fun
and we want to return to that but we
also wanted the heroes so we sort of
took those two elements and put them
together we're adding new mechanics as
well to kind of gel it all yeah better
but yeah that's the kind of drection
we're heading large-scale battles with
the league heroes that are very clear
for players to understand and devastate
with yeah cuz it's almost like two
completely different ways of
appreciating a game like big battles are
cool and all they're they're interesting
but you don't really have that much
agency and the sort of the moments
moment action that's happening there
absolutely and that was that that was
that was a role that we felt that the
heroes the elites
knows what we call them they could
fulfill that role excellently yeah like
they just come in they've got they
they're the agent of change if you will
you know they have these special
abilities and and when you see them in
action you can see how they can make a
real damage
real difference damage difference if you
on the field of battle yeah they're able
to sort of individually change the
course of about
in a way that like absolutely no sort of
top-up strategy can but it's very
different I guess like that's that's
you're kind of trying to have your cake
and eat it then this time because it's
you've got two different disparate
audiences how do you gel those two
things together so that they actually
work in tandem and they're not just like
contradicting each other lots of luck no
I now we're spending lot of time you
know trying to make sure that the the
two sides you know we have we still line
units that's sort of the bulk of your
army and they have a very critical role
to play in supporting the elites so the
elites are kind of you know the
superstar is if you will right but in
order for those superstars to perform
you know just like any of the football
on the we feel that we've been watching
all week right
you need that team to support the
superstars and we're having a little you
know what we're doing is making sure
that their roles for the line units
really play into the elites in the clips
that we'll see you know there's a an
imperial knight which is the largest
unit we've ever built right in a battle
it she she's fantastic awesome that
arranged but she's very weak to melee
right so if somebody runs up to her they
can really ruin her the line unit circle
me the ones that keep that I'm away mmm
so here we see some a battle clip you
know we've got Lady Solaria blasting
away with her to Gatling guns
we've got tats bull reins with
flamethrowers it looks beautiful
yeah we've had a lot of fun working on
it and you know our graphics teams like
are rendering programmers are phenomenal
our artists are incredible they've you
know absolutely knocking it out in terms
of one of the things we really wanted to
make sure we delivered on was yeah
large-scale battle but clarity and
within that battle so you can understand
what was happening moment to moment and
so we've been really focusing on like
delivering that clarity in a variety of
ways scale of units the visual effects
lots of feedback loops and so when you
press a button you see something you see
a tell you know they're about to do
something you see this something you
have a great payoff you know and and
like you can see it ladies Larry they're
just did her Gatling barrage which he
she does takes her to Gatling gun arms
and just as a sort of this cross fire
with which just wrecks anything in front
of her you know so she's yes she's
really
exciting to play with we've got assault
Marines jumping in to cover you know
we've got a new version of cover for the
game we we thought that in sort of
service of that clarity of gameplay we
thought you know and the size of the
battle hmm we thought hiding behind logs
and sandbags right probably wasn't gonna
cut it so it all breaks apart in there
right yeah yeah so what we have is this
concept of heavy cover and there's you
know when you go into it you take
control of it the the dome appears and
then you're safe
hmm you think you're safe forever but
you're not right it's got its own health
and if it gets destroyed it's gone
forever
melee units can also run in and right
okay yeah so you think you're safe with
the range students in there you it's
like a temporary emplacement but it can
be very temporary in the melee units run
in I like so what do you think when you
see this cuz I know you've played a
bunch of these types of strategy games
but you the dawn of War franchise is a
bit of a blind spot for you right yeah
so a little embarrassed I've never
played a war game or game but I am I've
said watch this footage and I'm really
really interested in Donnell war so for
someone like me who has a lot of a lot
of strategy experience I love Fire
Emblem I love XCOM can I can i play this
can I just jump right in
yeah absolutely what we're seeing here
in this footage is something that's
happening much later in the campaign
right and you know you look at it and be
like oh my god I can't do this no stay
away right but what we want to do over
the course of the game is build up that
complexity the first third of the
campaign is all about layering that
complexity on so using the new mechanics
giving you lots of time to exercise with
them and get used to them and then
adding more and then that anymore and so
the by the time you get to this
controlling this kind of army in this
kind of conflict it's old hat you'd be
happy you have no problem doing it so
for for other players like me who maybe
haven't been in been involved in this
franchise before it's a good place for
them to start absolutely yeah that's one
of our big goals and we wanted to do it
from a variety of ways one is ease of
entry into the gameplay another is we've
got a campaign that tells the story of
tells three factions stories so we've
got the Space Marines the orcs and the
Eldar each one of them has a sort of a
representative who's the voice the the
perspective of the of the care of the of
the race so Gabriel Angelo's he's the
chapter master of the Space Marines he
is character we've had in the dawn of
war series for quite a while and he's
making a big return he's going to be the
you know the the perspective of the
space marines the orcs and Eldar each
have their own and as we go through the
campaign we're gonna weave their stories
together so instead of having three
separate campaigns we have one
interwoven campaign first mission Space
Marine next mission is orcs next mission
is El dire and so you do something in
the first mission that you might see
paid off in a second and have another
perspective on it in the third so we
want to have sort of mini arcs of kind
of this really cool like you know what
everybody's the hero of their own story
right and it's you know the Warhammer
40k universe is very grim dark it's very
grey hmm there's lots of you know the
space brains you know you think normally
they're the good guys but the Emperor
who they all serve he sacrifices a
thousand citizens a day and stay alive
alright so I guess he really wants to
stay alive I like the idea of yeah it's
a you don't have to wait like two years
for the next expansion pack or four
years with next expansion pack to see
the other side of the battle yeah yeah
yeah that's a very interesting unique
way of doing it and we've got a bunch of
questions coming in from the child as
well I just want to get one of them in
here quick
but voke asking can you use say how many
battles have big the battles can be how
many squads units are we talking about
this this footage well not this
particular footage but the sort of stuff
you'll see in in these roles in on the B
roles is reflective of the kind of scale
of conflict we know we've got a full III
demo playthrough that we're going to be
releasing on YouTube and twitch ongoing
so players can see that and say okay I
can see see the whole mission and
they'll give them a good sense of where
we're going with the scale of battles
they're pretty good you know we I've had
quite a few number of quite a few units
on on screen plus my elites and felt
like I could control them all right um
it's it's always interesting I mean the
Warhammer franchise hives like this
massive like built-in audience obviously
but obviously fans of this series as
well do you find that the sort of your
audience for this game are they sort of
do they go from you know realtime
strategy games to real
strategy game is that it's not kind of
who you're talking to are these people
who are like like your specific brand of
RTS and kind of like sticking with it I
think it kind of I think it's a variety
of place I think that's I think both of
those cases that you talked about are
some of the people we're targeting and
and fans that we've had in the past you
know we found with our fan base there is
a very passionate fan base you know they
like the games a lot they've stuck with
us for a long time and part of that is
because you know relic makes really good
RTS games and in the dawn of our
universe but we also do a lot of support
stuff so arc fans are really important
to us so like earlier this year we
released the Necron overlord for The
Last Stand mode right so you know this
is a game that's like seven seven years
old right and we're still releasing
content for it
it's so yeah our fans are really
important to us and hopefully with this
game will you know will appeal to those
people are hopping between RTS is that
are new to RTS is and maybe get some
converts as well from people who haven't
been you know in in who don't hop and
have been loyal to other brands maybe
we'll get some of those guys yeah folks
as well you know I'm I love I love their
animations it looks really awesome yet
the lighting is the during the battle it
actually because like that you know
there are artists with bigger battles
happening I'm sure but if there's
something about the sort of the the men
of action that's happening all over the
screen that makes it feel like you know
what there's probably enough happening
here I know that yeah that it's a it's
all good well that was a big thing for
us you know when we were looking at when
we were starting to develop the game we
looked at obviously other titles and a
big thing for strategy games we looked
at MOBAs right right and we said well
geez you know what kind of things could
we learn from MOBAs that we could maybe
apply to our kind of game and the
biggest thing we took was clarity of
gameplay right so being able to tell
moment to moment where your hero is
doing in a MOBA is critical you know the
tells the actions the results we wanted
to capture all that and bring as much of
it as we could to our game and that was
a big informing element for our art
style it was like making sure there's a
clarity of gameplay at all time you can
see some of that here the last cannons
devastators are firing their last
cannons the wraith guards you can see
the beams are growing more intense the
longer they're on so
dart off as a small yellow beam they amp
up to green the longer they go and they
do more damage over time but it's tough
for them to do that because the other
guys users are firing back these guys
are just you know that's quite the
Mexican standoff that's happening there
right now over a flaming gold yeah as
well these are dreadknots and you may
have seen them in dawn war one right
there you know we've had in pretty much
all of our dawn of wars for the space
marines they used to be the big
mamajamas on the battle you know
compared to Salaria and the Imperial
night you know not so much yeah yeah but
there was a wonderful line unit that
just wreak havoc in melee combat a
flamethrower is on their arms they can
do these ground pounds hopefully we'll
see some of that here there's some
flamethrowers they have this fun power
gin to action and there was there was a
ground pound just splashes everybody
around them so they're critical line
unit have you shown off any other new
units sort of in that sort of scale
around there we've seen obviously that
the bigger units as well well you know
what we talked we got the line units
that are all around this thing around
this scale and then we've got the elites
right and so we've got hopefully we'll
see some footage of that Gabriel
Angelo's for example isn't elite bigger
than your average tactical marine he's
got a giant demon smashing hammer and
he's got some really cool abilities that
allow him to turn the tide about like
jump across chasms or I smash on the
landing or create a one of his things
abilities is retribution and it forms an
energy dome around him that doesn't
transmit damage but also reflects fire
so anybody firing at him suddenly
they're they're eating their own bullets
or if you time it right you can bounce a
grenade back at the thrower which is
awesome excellent that's the type of
like sort of micro you can already do if
you're if you're looking at this massive
massive battle that's right are you guys
talking about multiplayer at all I mean
that's such a huge element of these
games and especially the longevity of
them as well we love multiplayer
absolutely and the multiplier we're
playing at the office right now is a
blast or I mean a lot of fun iterating
on that making sure it's as tight as we
finding the exploits using them against
your coworkers that's all yeah our
opponents are hopefully our victims but
sadly I'm usually the victim Oh
campaign lead so I'm like you know Riya
player designers all have the edge yeah
you're the soft touch in the office you
were the artists are probably good I
don't I don't take anymore cash bets
well you saw here this is really cool
the faction mechanic for the Marines is
the drop pods mmm it's called death from
above and players we've had them in the
past they do a general area buff yeah
now players can choose what units come
down in them that was awesome
yeah so in this case that middle one had
a dreadnought in it right you can it's
always it's a real tide changer right
like if you're like I think I'm being
rocked a bit drop some drop pods on on
your opponents and actually on them just
knock back yeah it's all it there on the
road it's good times that's excellent
is there any other features that people
have been asking for I mean a very
passionate fan base as we've said before
do you think the the audience is kind of
they've wanted this because you said
like you're getting pulled in obviously
to sort of different different
directions with it and what's the
reception been like so far from the dawn
of war faithful other receptions been
great
yeah it's been really good yeah we
started yet you could characterize it as
sort of we went in different directions
yeah oh really we sort of trying what
we're trying to do is evolve it right so
we had the large-scale battles cool
traditional RTS and then to sort of a
squad much more personal scale yeah well
and now we're bringing that lens back
out but we're bringing all of the things
that we're doing are kind of fit very
well within the dawn of war universe and
you know the Warhammer 40k is all about
endless war yeah right infinite war
infinite endless oh here we go
these guys are assault terminals yeah
there's very heavy melee elite and what
they can do is they can teleport hmm so
if the enemy thinks they're safe in
their heavy cover these guys can
teleport in jet inside and really really
wreck them from within
beat them up my lifestyle when are we
looking at seeing more of zonna war 3
when you guys be talking about
multiplayer when looking to release well
we're looking to release on PC and 2017
ok
over the next over the rest of the year
we'll be revealing more about the other
races and their gameplay styles you know
we're really excited like the Space
Marines have a very distinctive gameplay
style yeah
they filled the fewest numb units on the
field of battle but they're also some of
the strongest right we call them sort of
the tip of the spear hmm with the Eldar
they're much faster moving but more
fragile so they're kind of all about
that we call them the sword wind
hit-and-run tactics and the orcs are the
bane e AK horde you know they have the
most units on the battlefield so it's
really exciting so we're excited to show
those things off over the rest of the
year that's good stuff it must be a big
undertaking to like because you
supported Donal war two for so long I'd
obviously been expansion Paxton and
everything else what does it feel like
sort of starting this one and being like
okay we're gonna get a game I'm gonna be
working on this for a good like five
years is a good feeling is it nice to
sort of like shake off the the the
previous game and get into something new
well yeah you know it's anytime you work
in a game and you get the chance to make
the next version yeah all those ideas
you couldn't do on the previous one
they're all brimming right they're all
ready to go and our blue sky
brainstorming sessions were ridiculously
fun right there's so many ideas being
tossed out because the team is really
passionate about the game they've got a
lot of history with the game you know on
this version of it we've been working on
it for about two and a half years oh wow
so obviously there was some stuff done
prior to Sega acquiring Yannick but you
know what's a guy's a partner they've
been great they've been giving us a lot
of support and advice and they've
allowed us to really focus on making you
know hopefully the best dawn of warrior
that we can six of that's our goal yeah
Brett this pro league campaign leap
campaign campaign lead campaign leaves
Allen or three thank you so much for
coming in and you enjoy the rest of your
electronic triple thank you very much
for having me cheers awesome thanks for
all the questions that came in folks as
well we'll be back in a second all new
RTS fans stick around halo wars 2 is
coming on we should get you guys to like
have a little have a fight yeah you both
came at around like 2009 as well over
the previous versions it's like yeah we
back in just a second folks there
you're watching the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airheads bites